[Applause]
well i'd like to welcome you back to
down the middle
uh every single time i have a guest i
say they're a special guest
and that you're in for a treat and all
the cliches that i can pull out to try
and pump up the conversation that i know
i'm about to enjoy that i know that you
will enjoy listening to
but i've yet to ever say a brother from
another mother
and that's who we've got with us today
we've got peter bookvar
he's chief investment officer of the
bleakly advisory group
thanks dan my sister that's right yup
i'm gonna tell a funny story about the
end of
fed up and so as i was getting to the
end of the book and you walked through
the manuscript with me in the whole way
there was a scene in the king cole bar
in new york city and we had brought
together
sir arthur cashion and then howard
silverbladt of brooklyn who's you know
the king of the s p 500 and you
beer goggles bookvar and me
and richard fisher and it was it was a
send-off
if you will it was the closing of a
chapter of an
era in which you were through me as a
conduit
one of the chief advisors in terms of
where your views were
on the market to richard fisher in his
own final speech as president of the
dallas fed
he referenced beer goggles so um
why don't you why don't you give me your
reflections on what it was like
to become so close to richard he still
reads you
and then you can tell us how long the
bar has been at closing time because
it's been last call for a long
time peter well uh luckily
for for us uh richard was one of the the
rare
outside the box fed thinkers uh
he was not your phd economist he
had real life experience uh he had
market experience managing
money uh he had actually as you
know is better than anybody just
incredible amounts of different type of
experiences but importantly that private
sector experience
that allowed him to sort of view the
business world
and the the place of monetary policy
within that
from a different angle uh than the the
standard conventional
phd's at the fed that it seemed like
once you
walked in the door there you all drank
the same kool-aid and
and all had you know the same answers to
every question
and that's what really attracted me
to to him and listening to his thoughts
whether he was
a voting member that particular year or
or not uh he always wanted to hear what
his
what his frame of thought was because he
knew he was going to be likely different
than
the consensus and where everybody else
stood
and having the chance that particular
night to meet him for the very first
time
was was certainly a pleasure obviously i
heard so much about him
through you and and you having the
opportunity to to work with him for so
many years
and and and you as as as outside the box
thinkers as i know
on on on the world and the fed uh it
seemed like it was a perfect match and
uh to be able to actually hang out
with both of you at the same time in
person in the same room
was uh was pretty special i i'm not sure
thinking back on that night whether
richard was happier to be in the room
with arthur or arthur was happier to be
in the room with us and we were maybe
just spectators peter
but we all got to marinate ice cubes
together and be with two
luminaries uh of the market and i will
never
i'll never give back those memories um
are there any richard fisher's
on the federal open market committee
today i think esther george
um unfortunately she doesn't give that
many speeches
but the ones that she has given over the
last couple years
uh she seems to to be very
independent-minded
and and and sees things more similar to
us
i guess you can say uh and and richard
as well
i think robert kaplan is not not as
as much as as as richard uh in terms of
like
the you know the dallas fed you know
frame of thought
i think he's he's more of the consensus
guy even though he
he does uh i have plenty of private
sector experience and
and certainly has his own views and that
thinks different than others
particularly
you know recently saying that you know
he he was the really the first one to
actually say let's taper sooner or later
so i definitely give him credit for that
uh
outside of that unfortunately there
really
aren't many um yeah yeah it's
interesting peter i'll share an anecdote
with you
from uh somebody who joined the dallas
fed
uh shortly after kaplan had joined um
but he he heard that when when richard
came into pre-briefs before the fomc
that i mean richard survives on very
little sleep four hours a night or so
uh and he would come into the fomc
briefing and there'd be all of us
around the table and he would have
tabbed
and marked and annotated the entire huge
briefing booklet
and he would sit down and say since this
book has been written
what can you tell me has happened since
and that was it he didn't want any
and apparently kaplan has the full
socratic the meetings go on for hours
and hours and hours and
everybody regurgitates what they've
written it's interesting
that uh it's interesting that it's so
hard to duplicate
him at the fed we might have gotten
close
with uh with judy shelton but it is
interesting to see peter and you can
give me your thoughts on him
uh because since fed transcripts were
uh were started to be transcribed in
uh we've seen i can count them on one
hand
governors dissenting it's so rare
and yet we have this new this new guy on
the street this christopher waller
person
who i wasn't expecting much from and yet
there he was speaking very plainly with
kathleen hayes
recently and saying you know it's a
white-on housing market let's get out of
that
let's get out of the mbs space the
mortgage back security space what what
are your thoughts on a governor
speaking forthrightly well i think it
was
and correct me if i'm wrong i i think
this is right that
wayne angel might have been the last
that governor that dissented at a
at a greenspan meeting and we haven't
seen one since
it was refreshing to hear what waller
said
uh without a doubt i think the key
question with what he said and what some
others is that there's one thing to
express
the concerns like we know the easy way
of a fed member
to say that they're watching they like
to we're monitoring it mm-hmm
what about they get the question what
about access is here oh we're monitoring
it what about this
issue here oh we're monitoring it uh so
to actually hear
what that means like while i gave some
substance to to
that line of thought was refreshing but
it gets down to
what do they actually do you know
there's one thing to talk about
yeah we're focused on because they don't
want to sound clueless
they want to let the world know that
they're on top of things
they're watching the same stats that you
are they have the army of
economists that work for them they're on
the phone all the time with all these
these businesses they're on the case
that's what they want us to think
but there's one thing to be on the case
but there's another thing how you
interpret what you hear and see
and then how you act upon it and that's
where i think
um there's there's been a disconnect for
a long time so you kind of
describe and you know you're one of the
first people i heard years ago
to say we've segued into
a confidence bubble with central bankers
worldwide i mean this is it sounds to me
that this is what you're describing
yeah there there's there's there's
obviously no humility with in in the
world of central banking and and
they've went from sort of being the
person behind
the curtain for a while to really being
center stage and that obviously goes
back to greenspan where
he loved his his lunches with the
president
and his hobnobbing with politicians and
he was the maestro and he
was the guy and he was the guy at the
helm that you can have confidence in
and that sort of feeling that he
uh got from the markets uh obviously
intensified over the years and we know
about the greenspan put and then the
bernanke put in the output and
and so on and so on and you know now
we're at a point where
uh that confidence is sort of
all-encompassing i mean you
you want to be able to approach the the
investing world
by looking at you know a company balance
sheet or income
statement or looking at credit metrics
for a bond or whatever
where unfortunately for for many it's
it's what's the fed gonna do
are they in an easing bias or tightening
bias and what's the level of qe and race
and then people then work backwards from
there and
it's it's um it's a strange
kind of world we're in but i think also
is that
one thing that we don't get and and how
i separate
a conventional fed thinker from one
that's not is
is are they self-reflective you know any
any successful ceo any successful
manager in a company they're going to
make mistakes
but it's those that pivot from those
mistakes and learn from those mistakes
that end up being successful
problem is with government and
institutional bureaucratic thinking
is there's never that reflection where
pivot it's always okay if what we're
doing is not working
let's just do more of it and if it
doesn't work then
we'll just do even more of it and
all looking for an end result i mean
when you think about it it's and again
these are all smart people with good
intentions but
you know they in a way they look at
monetary policy very simplistically
high rates bad low rates good well if
low rates are good
even lower rates are even better and if
you're in europe and japan if you get to
zero hey screw that
let's go even lower because that would
be even better
and never a time of reflection and
interestingly uh yesterday uh peter
pratt
who is the ex-chief economist at the ecb
uh he was asked okay so here we are
seven years into negative interest rates
what do you think and he's admitted that
that was supposed to be a
short-term thing well to my point with
government
there's never anything that's short-term
there's always a doubling down and
doubling down and doubling down
to the point where they can never get
out and there's certain no
change of policy i mean i've always been
critical of the ecb
in a sense that what 80 plus of lending
that takes place on that continent
flows through the banks so what does the
ecb do they
damage the profitability of the banks by
squeezing their loan margins which then
leads to less
lending and they think that that's going
to be good for growth
and and and get to the inflation that
they want
i mean it's you'd think that at some
point they would sort of reanalyze the
situation but instead they said
yeah negative rates is good and let's
just keep on doing more of it
and um so i think that that's the
problem and again we all make mistakes
it's it's the ability to acknowledge the
mistake and then pivot off that
that i think is is lacking in the world
of of of central bank thinking
so um before i jump into uh
the hot subject with you which is the
inflation debate
um what is your what's your favorite
if you were to be in the eccles building
around that big oval table
and they were they were to say mr
brookfire what is your go-to
economic indicator what what do you
think the most
telling revealing accurate
uh economic indicator is out there among
all of them that we have
so i i'd like to i it's hard for me to
pick one because i like to marry things
i like to i like to listen to a lot of
what companies say
i take it with a grain of salt i mean
you listen to any home builder
in 2005 2006 and and you think that
you know the the the world of whole
building would never stop on their
trajectory
and they didn't see what was coming and
you talked to any bank ceo in the summer
of 07
you know they had no idea what was
coming their way so
you listen to what they say but you take
with a grain of salt but it is i think
um a good finger on the pulse of things
by hearing about
companies in certain industries that are
affected by things that
other industries are as well you know
you take the obviously the semiconductor
shortage now it's not just an auto
executive
that's feeling the pinch it's also
plenty people in in the tech business
too
that is filling that pinch as well and
hearing what they have to say and what
they're seeing i think is important
but getting to my point earlier you
almost want to take them with a grain of
salt
companies certain companies are
different parts of the supply chain
you take like intel for example the
problem that everyone always had with
intel is that they were sort of at the
bottom end of the chain they were like
the last one to know
so whenever there was a slow down here
they didn't really see it until
way after the fact so it wasn't a
relevant company to sort of get their
accurate forecast of how the next couple
of quarters were going to look so
i like to look at some of the companies
that are sort of like real time where
things are happening quicker
uh particularly anything related to the
concern because we know that's
such a dominant part of the economy and
getting a sense of how the consumer is
behaving
since that filters into so much of
everything else i think is important
i mean obviously i like to look at you
know the cpi numbers or pc but by the
time you see them
you know it's somewhat after the fact i
mean obviously commodity prices i like
to look at
uh but a lot of the data we look at it's
there's always
a lag now we have to deal with that it
is what it is you're never going to get
really anything that's
such real time so i think it's important
to just to marry this all together
uh rather than just sort of picking one
here one there
because i think it gives a more complete
mosaic to things i mean obviously weekly
jobless claims are key
um but there's always a story behind
that firing there's always a story
behind
that person who either came off
continuing claims or or stayed on it
because they didn't want to take that
job
and and sort of trying to find
corroborating evidence around that
i think gives a better fuller picture
yeah i think we're all kind of waiting
for september the 6th
to to finally have a cleaner read if you
will
on jobless claims going forward because
in many ways the federal government and
the fiscal uh
the fiscal stimulus has been in place in
an emergency mode now since
april of 2020 uh and you know what we're
learning as
states exit these unemployment benefit
federal unemployment benefit programs
early is that we're you know it doesn't
take quite as much time to get an uber
driver
it doesn't take quite as much time to to
wait in a restaurant
to get service so it's incredible to me
and and i think that that's i mean maybe
you can speak to because you've been
following monetary policy for as long as
i have
but this is kind of the first foray into
kind of a double-barreled
approach because we've had monetary
plus fiscal and what difference do you
think that's going to make
in the current episode well it's it's a
great point because it's it's the fiscal
side is
really what we lacked in in the uh
recovery
after the housing bubble uh and even it
it
almost went to the reverse when we had
sequestration where we really limited
the pace of government spending and
where it was just monetary policy trying
to
light the fire even though that was
really sort of
lost its its touch uh where now as you
say
we have a combination and no doubt that
and and you you just wrote about it and
quoting
um you know milton friedman about you
know too much money chasing too few
goods
and it's really the money part
really comes from the fiscal side it
only comes from the monetary side
is if you borrow it to then chase those
goods
so here you had the cheap money on
addition to the fiscal side of
creating way too much money chasing then
a supply problem
that that we currently have so it also
gets to
is why do central bankers to begin with
want higher inflation and there is no
central banker that will be able to show
you a model
and say that say two percent is what is
healthy for an economy because that
model does not exist
yeah the only reason why they want the
two percent
is because theoretically they think if
inflation is at two
that means in a perfect world we have
our dead funds rate or
overseas or banks their overnight rate
at at least that or higher
therefore in an economic downturn we
have rates to cut
that's the only reason why they picked
that number but getting to the point of
no self-reflection
no pivoting well being married to an
arbitrary number
i mean look at the japanese kuroda's
been
trying to achieve that number since
2013.
if he was an executive ad in a company
he would have been fired in 2015
let alone still be around in 2021 and
the same
can surely be said for members of the
ecb and other
central banks but what's also scary is
this you know getting back to the group
think
japan basically tried this for a while
and instead of learning from those
mistakes
we have all then tried to repeat it and
thinking that there would be a different
result
and you and i have spoken about this in
the past you take the reserve bank of
australia i respect it a lot for
for decades because they never fell for
the trap of negative real interest rates
they always felt that it was good to
have
their um administered rates at or above
the level of inflation
and they never experienced a lot of the
booms bust that the rest of us did now
granted they
had certain doubts of housing excesses
but they never fell for it
until of course recently where they just
sort of had to drink the same kool-aid
that everyone
had drank and all thinking that again
there was me a different result and
i just can't understand we have we have
a world of evidence
of the the efficacy efficacious nature
of it and
and the horms of of monetary policy and
they just all feel the need to do the
same thing i just
i just can't for life me understand why
they've all gone down that hole
well and it seems to your point like uh
in terms of no self-reflection it seems
like they're doubling down
we had the fed come out with a new
inflation regime
last year and now we've had the european
central bank
joined them in saying that we're going
to let inflation run hot
take me back to the basics because
something i learned from you a long time
ago
is that even the inflation metrics that
the fed
follows understate inflation by design
tell me about for people who who don't
read you constantly
what are the what are the flaw designs
in these inflation metrics
well you take take cpi for example and
then we'll get to pce
well first they have and then pc2 has
the similar the substitution thing
that they assume okay if you like
chicken
and the price of chicken goes up to such
an extent
they assume that you'll stop eating
chicken and you'll switch to beef
well some people don't want to switch to
beef they just want to eat chicken
and are paying a higher and higher price
for chicken and there's no substitution
there
so their cost of living continues to go
up
and they can't offset it with something
else then they have
hedonic adjustments where they basically
embed
in an inflation calculation in
improvement in
a particular product and of course it's
mostly reflected in
autos where or even computers that if
the
technological investment from one year
to the next
is up to an extent uh
that can offset any price increase in
that item
even though i may not have an option in
in any other item if i want to buy a car
and there's in
a certain price point you know there's x
number of models within that price point
if they've
all gone up a certain percent i don't
care if i have all these new bells and
whistles in the car
i still have to pay up three four five
percent for that car relative to last
year
so my cost of living is going up in the
real world
it can't be hedonically adjusted lower
and then we also have a mix of
methodologies where
and you are actually very good at
calculating
what the percentage uh
of one's sort of expenses are allocated
to housing of being around 40
which happens to be the rate at cpi
whereas pc is about half that
uh and and healthcare is a greater
percentage and in pce
the healthcare component as opposed to
cpr where healthcare is calculating
out-of-pocket costs
pce is measuring medicare medicaid
reimbursement rates
and you ask any doctor any hospital what
they just got
reimbursed for for a consultation or a
procedure or surgery
from medical medicaid and it's it's
peanuts it's it's essentially government
price fixing
uh in an uneconomic fashion
the price of of this good or service
within healthcare
that artificially suppresses it and
explains why that in addition to the
lower
allocation to housing why pce typically
runs
50 basis points below cpi and
conveniently the fed which never paid
attention to pce for
decades all of a sudden said you know
what screw pc
cpi we're going to focus more pce so
here we have this
this whole monetary policy construct
predicated on their pick and choose
of an inflation gauge and i argue the
one they
chose is artificially depressed in its
largest
component and stanley fisher former vice
chair of the federal reserve would agree
with you by the way and alan greenspan
who said that the best i you know the
most ideal inflation target was zero
percent
would agree with you uh looking back in
history it was bernanke and yellen
who were determined to impose that two
percent inflation target
and right minute green spam was out the
door there it was
yeah i mean we think about inflation
we have technology that take the
computer and then the systems we're on
right now
that they just go down in price every
year as companies become more productive
and they they make up whatever they lose
in price they make it up in volume
so let's just say the price of of a
laptop goes down
two percent a year well that means that
something has to go up um
a lot more to offset that decline
in that price so i always want to
ask a central bank okay you want two
percent
what do you what price do you want to go
up two percent a year you don't like
gasoline prices when they go up
okay because they they always that get
that spooks them that's annoying they
don't want
prices to go up uh they like it when
technology
suppresses improv okay so what prices do
you want to go up
to offset the prices that typically go
down and that gets to the point where
it ends up being the services side of
the economy that ends up being that
upward inflation pressure that offsets
that natural uh downward pressure on
goods that benefit from again production
efficiency and technology advancements
that
is just a natural suppressant on on on
prices where we
do things more productively and and
prices uh you know are a result of that
so our mutual friend david rosenberg uh
explains that that goods consumption is
multiple factors of services consumption
and what we've just come through with
stimulus check 1.0
stimulus check 2.0 stimulus check 3.0
and
more fiscal stimulus than we've seen
since
world war ii that really
it really disturbed the traditional
construct that you just described
between goods inflation and services
inflation
well we do spend a lot on goods relative
to services
but the services
is 60 of cpi and and
and that is because of of the housing
component so
to take out rents as a cost of living
and and yes only about 35 of the people
of households rent
but i argue the 65 percent that own
they're paying three four five percent
higher property taxes every single year
so that there's no property tax
component
within these inflation numbers but
i mean my property taxes are double what
they were
when i moved in and no no no central
bankers is taking that into account
you know they're looking at rent so i
argue that to take out
the cost of living uh in
housing and and just look at what people
are spending on goods and services and
services not including that that
necessarily the housing
is not really accurate or reflecting um
the people's rise in the cost of living
yeah i buy a car once every three years
if you lease
maybe you'll hold it for five to ten if
you if you own yeah i'm only going to
buy a laptop
once every call of five years yeah well
that that's always the case and we
definitely bunched up
the situation on the good side but
there's no stopping services inflation
so the whole inflation transitory or not
debate is where do goods prices go from
here
because you can be confident on where
services prices are going
well and i think peter to your point and
you and i don't necessarily see eye to
eye on the transitory not transfer
debate
but you can set that whole debate to the
right-hand side
uh our our mutual friend arthur cassin
i'm gonna bring his name back up he
heard
dan niles on cnbc mentioned the year
and so he he prompted us to have a look
at what the discussion was around the
table in 2004.
all i did was search for the word
transitory
there it was but in the background
in 2004 to your point we had housing
prices
really really revving up and
if you looked at that april of 2004
when the the cpi headline cpi was 1.7
and it popped up in in um
sorry popped up in april went from march
and then it popped above 2
and it popped above 3 but it was the
housing costs
that had that were becoming entrenched
that ended up pushing the cpi beyond
five
it was 5.7 in october 2005.
that was your that was housing and it
showed up with a really really long lag
and i think that regardless of what
happens with goods
i think the fed's toast because of
housing right now
i agree it's it's a it's a really
difficult
spot they're in and one of the fallacies
of running things hot
because hot always overheats and then
quickly flames out
where it's really better to have
something that's more consistent and
stable
rather than than hot and and it goes
back to
you know who is the fed to decide
you know the the peace at which we are
going to
you know interact with each other
economically it's always this
speed up slow down thing and and it gets
to
the whole thing about monetary policy is
that monetary policy doesn't
increase the economic pie it just
shifts around where the money flows and
pulls forward economic behavior and and
one thing that i've always
liked to say is that you know one of the
one of the things that the fed
took on under bernanke was this whole
forward guidance thing
and and they imputed in their models
that if we tell the markets
and the world that we're going to keep
rates in a specific level for a specific
period of time
but that is stimulative when in fact
it's actually
the exact opposite because you don't
create
any sense of urgency by saying rates are
going to stay low for years
because people just can just sit and
wait whereas
if the cost of money just went up and
down
based on the supply and demand for it we
we would act differently
we we would behave more um in line with
where our savings rate are where our
investment needs are
rather than sort of being pushed and
nudged and forced into
doing things now before you really
wanted to do it because when you think
about monetary policy it's like
it's they're they're trying to make a
deal with you okay home
okay wannabe homeowner i'll make a deal
with you instead of taking
two years to save up for that down
payment how about this
i'll lower your mortgage rate right now
and
you go buy that home now instead of
waiting and so you're not shifting that
household's desire to own home you're
just shifting the timing of it
and then of course that so much has been
pulled forward and then you get
an inevitable hangover with no real
increase
in the long-term possibilities of the
economy in fact you actually depress it
because at the same time you're creating
this incentive to take on all this debt
that's what also boggles the mind is
that you know these central bankers have
have made them seem like they're heroes
and that they're these noble figures and
but all they're doing is just they're
debt dealers
instead of drug dealers and they're debt
dealers and they're in business to make
you take on
debt because that's the only way that
they have an impact is by
you taking on debt and and pulling
forward economic behavior
and not waiting till tomorrow to buy
that car is to take on debt
and let's look around let's look around
at the debt levels in the world
this was aided and abetted and
encouraged by uh the nobility of central
bankers
we used to have janet yellen running
instead
and she was she was
oversaw the most glacially slow
tightening policy
in the 100 plus year history of federal
reserve
and when she used to be up in front of
congress uh and they would ask her about
the markets or the banking system or
regulation that her eyeballs would roll
into the back of her head
so now we have this person running the
treasury department
take mnuchin for what he was good at in
between
we know he profited from the subprime
crisis for example but do you think that
that janet yellen is the is the right
person to have at
treasury in the event of another
disaster in the overnight rates market
as we sit here talking about
the fed's overnight facility pushing a
trillion dollars
i don't know for sure but you can
probably bet that
she does not have a bloomberg terminal
in her office and
she's not checking quotes uh just to see
where
where markets are now maybe she gets a
call and say okay
janet we're about to sell to your paper
today this is the pricing
but you make the great point that
it the the crisis is that we've had
at the treasury level have been market
induced
and if you don't understand the workings
of the market
well how can you really best respond to
that i mean
janet of course is uh a believer in
and the powers of the government whether
it's the fiscal powers of the government
or the monetary powers of the government
and
you know they can spend the right amount
of money and they can incentivize in
their own way
and get some sort of outcome while she
seems to be very nice and smart you know
she
lived her career in surrounded by
four walls and econometric models
and and not out there and running a
business and
meeting payroll and we're even trading
the markets where
you know the markets have their their
their problems but the great thing about
markets
is that they quickly adjust when they're
wrong whereas you know to my point
earlier
a government bureaucrat doesn't shift
when they're wrong they just
they just do more and um it it is a
worrisome thing to think that if we ran
into
trouble how would she uh respond other
than
let's just spend money and have the fed
you know cut rates to zero and do q8
that seems to be
just what's the only thing that's in
their playbook or
um something that i haven't seen before
but it's probably similar
so uh so the treasury department
politics congress uh in august of 2011
we were at camp kotak when
standard poor's downgraded the debt of
the united states
and we're 10 years on from that junk
shirt now
and at the end of july we've got the
debt limit being hit
all over again uh s p when they
downgrade the united states they did so
because
entitlement spending had not been
addressed nor had tax policy in order to
pay for
all of the entitlement spending so that
those were that was it those are their
two main reasons
you haven't addressed entitlement
spending and you haven't basically
raised
taxes to pay for all of this
extraordinary spending so here we are
a decade on and instead of looking in
the rearview mirror at midterms that
were
a slaughter we're looking forward to the
midterms of
2022. peter have have markets
begun to price in what's to come
in this summer of 2021 well it's it's
it'll be
interesting because politically if
you're if you're on the democratic side
you do not want to lose one house of
congress
november of next year so you'll want to
spend
any amount of money to sort of buy
yourself
uh maintenance of of control next
november
uh the problem is is that because the
the the um
the control is is on a razor thin edge
it's going to be difficult so you're
going to have i know
getting back to our friend rosie with
this the fiscal cliff worries
um yeah there'll be worries but of
course now we're handing out
child tax credits so there's always a
form of money that that that's flowing
door to to try to keep things
afloat i think though that there will be
plenty of spending next year to try to
maintain
the economy at a certain level going
into november next year
and i think it will also be interesting
what happens with with powell
you know i think about like i i say you
know what if i try to i want to try to
imagine if i was in his
shoes on one hand i'd see what's ahead
and i say you know what i want to get
the hell out of here
let's hand the keys off to somebody else
well if that's your thought
maybe you want to start the taper
process and say you know what i started
the exit
but you really want to do it really slow
because you don't want to screw things
up ahead of february 2022 when you leave
you want to you want to leave when
things are calm
on the other hand maybe he wants to stay
but he'll have the same thought if he
wants to stay
he doesn't want to screw things up
either before february 2022 because he
wants to substantiate why he's there
and why he deserves a new term so while
they i believe are going to announce a
taper
you know at least initially it'll be
really glacial because
he doesn't want to screw it up and
that's what gets into
what the fed became under greenspan
versus what
was under paul walker who i know you
know you've hung out with
when he was alive which is amazing that
he didn't care he wasn't doing press
conferences
he did what he felt he needed to do
where now
uh that is obviously no longer a case no
politician
and no central banker wants to preside
over
any economic decline just politically
they just don't because you'll either
lose your job in the next election or as
a central banker
you know you you'll you're looked at and
bowed down upon and how can you
mess that up uh so to your original
question of
how we go into next year and what that
looks like
it's gonna be really interesting and it
gets
also ties in i believe to the story
on how that plays out because
we know for the last at least the last
13 14 years since
bernanke started qe and cut rates to
zero and then
all the central banks did whatever they
did what gave them
license to continue on was very low
rates of inflation
because we know obviously the criticism
initially was money printing
the textbooks say it's going to lead to
inflation when it never did
well they were able to do what they
wanted if inflation is not transitory
if i say you have to see then they have
less
options there's less there there's
it's it really limits not only their
ability to respond to any challenges
but it limits their ability to do things
on a timeline of their wishes because
you know as well as anybody a central
banker likes to have their own plan
and once they set up that plan they like
to stick to it
and if there's no inflation then they
have the opportunity to stick to it
but if you throw inflation it'll be like
throwing mud in the spokes of a bicycle
it could sort of like throw them off
where they can't go as fast as they want
or
the bike is going to turn one way when
they want to go the other way
so i think that that inflation story not
only is going to have a mainstream
impact
if it's not transitory and again it's if
it will have an impact on how markets
respond
and importantly how what the fed's
response function will be
will be in their control or will they
sort of be dragged along by the markets
yeah and again i think if you look back
to that 2004 episode what's so
fascinating is that they completely lost
control
because i i read a morgan stanley report
i wrote about this that single-family
housing rental
growth has was 11 and a half percent
in the year through the second quarter
uh rent uh
class a and class b apartment rentals uh
in the united states 9.2
year-over-year at the end of the second
quarter and this is this
this is morgan stanley speaking to the
people who are actually charging the
rents
this isn't an index that's conceived
this isn't some
impudent number this is the people who
are setting rents
and you know some of it has to do with
the rental eviction moratorium
because that's kind of held the market
in a state of suspension if you will for
a long time
that's ending but nonetheless this kind
of inflation
does not feel like it's something that
can be
pulled back easily because when you're
talking about an apartment lease or a
lease for a single family rental and
we're
we're still more renters than we've ever
really been
uh as a nation that's not something you
can reverse quickly that's a 12 month
lease
right and and it's and we know that
the hotter home prices get the hotter
rental rates get
but what's the alternative for the fed
is to put the brakes on
the housing market the market through
higher interest rates but then that
slows the economy
so it's doing the right thing
does does not include easy choices
but central bankers only want easy
choices that's why they always avoid
sort of saying no to the child that
wants more
candy or saying you know what i don't
yet want to do my homework so
that is to a point where i don't know
how this turns out and the interesting
thing now about the inflation
story is back then it really was mostly
in housing
now it's it's in so many other areas
that i think it gets to the importance
of
when main street really starts to feel
it which
when you look at the confidence numbers
we are seeing obviously an uptick in
inflation expectations
even though longer-term inflation
expectations have remained muted
because most people that we know
that sort of 25 to 50 40 year olds
we were we you know the upper end were
kids in the 1970s
we just assumed that any flare-up and
inflation will just
recede which obviously we hope it does
but what if it doesn't and and i'm not
talking about high inflation
i'm just talking about high er it's like
when you think about
three percent inflation for a couple of
years that's a problem
yeah um that's a problem because of its
impact on on on real wages because even
though
wages are going up it still is a crimp
on real wages
and the world's bond markets the level
of global interest rates
are just not prepared for anything that
is sustainable
i mean christine lagarde is at the poker
table
all in with her chips that this is
transit tour
and you know what i hope she's right
because none of us want to see something
that's
past transit but she's all in because
she can substantiate negative interest
and
all the qe they're doing if it's not
transitory
which is ironic because they don't want
they want it to be
i'm sorry they don't want it to be
transitory in order to get to their two
percent
but not understanding because they're
not market people that that consists in
two percent inflation in europe
with their bond market so there's
it makes your head spin oh it does make
your head spin and but what i'm
listening to
peter and this is something you've been
writing about increasingly is
because they're kind of damned if they
do they're damned if they don't they
don't have any easy choices
but are there any central bankers who
recall
a stagflationary era
and and that that that's kind of the
worst of all worlds at this point i mean
do you think that that is a potential
outcome
from the current episode given again it
sounds like
it sounds like central bankers have
backed themselves into a corner
so i like to see we're seeing
stagflationary
incidents stack reflationary stories in
certain
industries and housing is the perfect
example where we know that the lack of
inventory aggressive home price
increases
has slowed the pace of transactions that
is a stagflationary type
situation where you just ran prices too
hot
you look at uh certainly autos and
and you have managers that are having to
cut shifts and
and pause production for a couple weeks
because they can't get enough
supply of not just chips but steel and
aluminum and
and paint they can't even get paint on
time to
to paint the sides of the car so that is
sort of a staggered deflationary type
situation and we hear stories about
restaurants that can
staff seven days a week and they have to
be open six days a week
instead of being open till 11 they have
to close at 10
or 9 because they don't have enough
people that's stagflationary type
scenario so we're seeing it in bits and
pieces
uh if you're a home builder forget about
the price
but if you if it takes you i mean
i always like to look at home building
because i think i find it so interesting
it's sort of similar in a way
where if you look at if you're like an
auto assembly line
you're getting hundreds of parts from so
many different parts of the world
and everything really needs to come in
time because you
you can't get to this point unless
unless these points are done
and it's just like building a house like
you you you
you frame it but you can only frame it
if you get all the lumber and you can't
put up the sheetrock until you get the
electrician to put in
the background wiring and if you can't
get that
electrician because they can't get
enough product to put in the wiring
then your sheetrock is held up and if
your sheetrock is held up then you got
to push out getting
the the the tile where the wallpaper and
everything gets clogged
up and it actually gets into also a
discussion on
the whole just-in-time thing and just in
time
was was was a great thing because it
made things run efficiently
and if you're a company you didn't need
to stock
too much inventory and you had less
working capital needs
and you had a cleaner flow of things and
i argue with kova that
at least for a while just in time is
dead and you need to stop more things on
the shelf because you don't want to have
to tell your customer
that it's going to take two more months
to get a washer and dryer
if your customer is a home builder and
they now need to delay
you know finishing the house uh or or
getting an
hvac system because training carrier
just told you
you gotta wait a couple extra months so
you're gonna stock more stuff
that is that reduces your inventory
turns that's a drag on cash flows
and maybe you're going to have to raise
prices to sort of mitigate that
impact uh and and that is just
beginning so even when manufacturing
does sort of clear itself to an extent
it won't go back to uh the way that it
was pre-covered
well it's interesting you bring that up
peter because in discussions with
with housing experts they're hearing
they're hearing echoes of 2005 2006
from the public home builders the
private home builders are like
they can see down there they can see
over the horizon they can they can
envision
all of the lag times that you just
described
and at the end of that they can also see
faltering demand because so much demand
has been pulled forward
so you really are getting two separate
narratives right now from the public
versus the private home builders which
is just
fascinating and if you know you've been
following economics for as long as i
have i've never seen a cycle
act in such a compressed manner as what
we're seeing right now this is
really remarkable what we're seeing in
some of these indicators
it really isn't and to your point you
just made i mean if you're a world
whirlpool and you
and and toll brothers and polti and kb
homes are your big
big customers of yours they're your
priority
the small builder that maybe builds 5 to
10 to 20 homes a year
they're at the bottom of the list they
are not getting
that washer and dryer ahead of the big
home builders those big customers so
that is also going to create it's its
own problems
of what as well and it clogs things up
and getting back to housing
when you think about the if you make it
unaffordable for that first-time buyer
that means that that trade-up
buyer who owns a home wants to get a
bigger one well they have less people to
sell to
well and and they don't they don't move
out
now of course that first time buyers
being replaced by
investors and private equity and the buy
to rent and
and that is sort of maybe clearing some
of those homes but it's screwing that
first-time buyer
and then imagine and it may not be the
case let's just say
rates go up i mean our general
doesn't know what a mortgage rate is
with like a four handle
i'm not saying that rates are going to
go there but let's just say they did we
we will have locked in so many people
that are not going to want to give up
a three percent or two percent problem
that's down the line i'm not
saying that that's happening anytime
soon but it is
we've already seen it play out once
we've already seen mobility stunted
one time because of the last generation
of low mortgage rates so i mean we've
we've read this book before this could
easily repeat itself but even in a more
entrenched way
so the best thing to do there for if
you're if you're the new administration
is to is to reshape the federal reserve
based on your vision of what the u.s
economy should look like
i'm not i'm i'm positive that you saw
these headlines
and i i i have to ask for your reaction
to the idea of saying out loud
that i want to form a federal reserve
that
bids my doing that that carries out
fiscal policy what kind of a world are
we i thought this was an independent a
political institution i thought that
that was in the 1913 federal reserve act
well i our mutual friends mark gomez i
liked his
term used a while ago the fishery
combining the
the fed and treasury but what's
interesting is that
the i i don't want to criticize some
people for
just not fully understanding but you
know
again there's a very simplistic way that
some people in politics look at monetary
policies low rates good high rates bad
even though they're not looking at well
low rates is making
housing unaffordable for your
constituency it's
raising the cost of living above the
rate
above the increase in wages for your
constituency
and it is reducing therefore the
standard of living
of your constituency uh unfortunately
there's not enough people
that connect the dots and that gets to
one of the things that the central
bankers i talked about
them having license because of low
inflation they also have license because
not enough people understand what they
do
and what the impact that they do is on
daily lives of and of households and
businesses
yep most people don't understand they're
they don't
connect the dots and that's why
the fed has avoided a lot of public
criticism it's because people just don't
fully
get the influence that they have on so
many different things i was listening
to uh tv this morning and
a reporter was was interviewing uh
sherrod brown
um the the congressman and the question
was you know what can the fed do
about helping the wealth and income
inequality
and and obviously the question it
questioner didn't understand
and certainly shared sherry brown's
answer
clearly don't understand the fed's uh
reason for particularly wealth
inequality
and unfortunately if you don't
understand well then you're just going
to let them do
continues to do what they do you know
that was actually going to be my next
question was you know why is there
and you know what peter um i i'll be
jumping the gun if i get to this i'm
going to hold on to income and equality
for just a minute
uh and and just just hit on two subjects
climate change and diversity uh
do these have any place in central
banking do these have any role
in monetary policy
zero uh if if price stability
and employment are your main goals uh
now the ecb will say okay we're
uh sort of supporting climate change
because
we're no longer going to buy the bonds
of
of total in france and
we'll buy the bonds of uh wind farm
companies instead and i guess if that's
their their their
way of of climate change but the the
thing with climate change is
okay people we can argue
you know the extent of it but even if
you can to say okay we're having it
try to figure out what the economic
implications of it are
are virtually impossible you know if you
live in siberia
you're going to love a little bit of
global warming
if you live in in south florida or
dallas during the summer you may say you
know what it's a little bit too humid
you know i wouldn't mind a less humid
summer so
i don't even know how to quantify
the economic impact putting aside the
whole climate change
you know original discussion how do you
quantify it
and if you can't quantify it then how do
you
how do you make policy around something
you can't quantify agree on on all
counts
um and uh so now let's get back to
income inequality
so in theory well
first of all what what are your feelings
about where evaluations are right now
given we've described that a few things
could go wrong here and there going
forward that are not
in central bankers control but what are
your feeling i mean we're in the 99th
percentile evaluations
but yet if you're on my twitter feed or
your twitter evaluations
they've ceased to matter they don't they
don't matter anymore
right i like to say evaluations don't
matter until they do they can stay rich
for a while
and they will matter when they do and
yes so there's i think it's tough to
argue that they're not rich
particularly stocks trading at you know
high
low 20s multiple credit spreads that are
obviously tried
tight as a drum and triple c credit that
yielding less than six percent and
high yield or i should call it junk yeah
building level four i mean
things are rich we all know it it's just
a matter of when it matters
and historically speaking it does begin
to matter
when you get a change in interest rates
you get a change of monetary policy
you know that's when people pay more
attention
to valuations when the fed is easing
when rates are low
well there's no re what's the difference
between paying
30 times 40 times or 50 times earnings
or
for some companies a multiple sales it
doesn't really matter
but when the when when the tide turns
and
and the cost of money changes and where
monetary policy is shifting another way
well then people start to become a
little bit more discriminating on
valuations and we did get a taste of
that
in the first quarter with the rise in
interest rates and people said
let me rethink how much i want to pay
for this tax stock
and maybe that value stock trading at 10
times
earnings doesn't look too bad anymore
maybe that all of a sudden is attractive
if if the cost of money is going up and
i don't want to pay too much for that
other stock
now we're sort of kind of in a strange
position because rates have
fallen and we've shifted back to oh
let's just pay anything
for tech growth because that's the only
place we're going to get it
and who cares about valuation as long as
the company is growing
eventually that that hits a wall but
trying to figure out when
is obviously always very difficult and
you know managing money makes
it that much more difficult because
you either get get dogmatic and say you
know what i can't pay that
and then they that part of mark keeps
going up and you're missing it you got
clients calling you saying
how come i don't own this this and this
and you'd say well
it's trading too expensively i don't
want to pay up they left with you they
don't care about that
they want to own things that go up avoid
things that go
down and valuations in that context
don't matter
and and so even and this is probably
something you understand better than
most people
even as we've seen a reversal in that
spike in interest rates
gold has found a floor so i mean there
are certain myths
surrounding gold and maybe you can help
dispel
some of them so i like to look at gold
as
just trading off two things where the
dollar goes and eventually all fiat
currencies
because you do have times when gold and
the dollar can route at the same time
but also where real rates are don't look
at gold as uh
as the world is falling apart the sky is
falling don't look at gold as
as a safe haven when there's
geopolitical problems
don't look at gold as a hedge against
the stock market just traded off those
two things real rates
and the direction of the dollar and fiat
currencies generally
we had a pullback in in gold and silver
this year when we saw
um you know the shark rise in in in
rates
uh because basically real rates even
though it was it was joined by a rising
and inflation expectations real rates
pretty much bottomed out
uh last summer now real rates have
fallen again over this past week
with a sharp drop in interest rates but
then the dollar has rallied so while
gold may have gotten been a beneficiary
of the drop in real rates
the balance in the dollar with the
dollar index now called 92 ish
93 ish has been been a headwind
but me being a bull and long gold and
silver
it's been sort of a maddening experience
because you think that
that the world is really set up for
a nice rally in gold silver but if i am
right
and again if that inflation will remain
sticky here for longer
i expect real rates will remain very
negative
and i'm long-term bearish on the dollar
because of
basically the twin deficits of of the
budget deficit the trade deficit
having a decent correlation over a long
period of time with the dollar
uh that gold and silver will have their
day
uh there aren't many assets that are
down
50 from where they were 10 years ago and
silver qualifies
and even taking a step back from gold
gold's you know 1700 actually 1800-ish
it's only 200 ish off its all-time 4
thousand year high
so if that's some stylus to other gold
bugs out there 4
000 year high um so so what
what of the idea that that
cryptocurrency is a substitute
for hard money i have a lot of respect
for
the whole crypto space and and and the
basis of bitcoin i mean we
we know bitcoin was created in response
to
wow we have central bankers that are
printing all this money we need to
create something that that
has that is finite in nature can't be
printed away it could be used as a
medium exchange certainly a store of
value
and uh yeah digital so what it's still
limited
so there there's a lot of similar
thinking being the gold bull and and
appreciating
appreciating that uh my only issue with
with bitcoin generally and then we'll
get broader
crypto for a second is is that i don't
know if bitcoin should be worth 50 bucks
50 000 500 thousand or five million i
don't know
i think in ten years twenty years
bitcoin will still be around i just
don't know what price it should be
i'm much more confident that yeah crypto
is a new technology
it's very fascinating right now this
whole d5 thing is really only for
a small portion of the financial sector
and yeah this could grow and the
tokenization and so on and so on
and it's something that i'm trying to
teach myself and i'm trying to learn
about it because if it is something
that has legs i want to understand it
and and hopefully
be be a part of it in some way in terms
of
you know investing uh but bitcoin
replacing gold
that is complete nonsense something
that's been around for 13 years is not
going to replace something that's been
around for 4 000 years it's just not
going to happen
now they can complement each other for
sure
but i'm just more comfortable owning
gold uh
than owning bitcoin but again i have no
opinion on where the price of bitcoin is
going and i respect
the thought process and the bold case
for it but
it's still still trying to get my hands
around something that you can't
physically hold and touch i've got i've
got bad news for you peter
um that you just showed some serious
humility and you you do
not qualify to sit on the federal
reserve board i just
i don't want to ruin your day i i do not
um so take so
it wasn't too long ago there were
protesters storming the bonk de france
so there's a difference between where we
are today
as a society versus where we were
going into the financial crisis and that
the bursting of the housing bubble
there is a greater awareness i think
of the the role that the fed has played
and let's say hypothetically that we are
going to have three busts
inside of a 20-year period do you think
have you seen have you noticed uh
because of this inequality divide
have you noticed because i have but but
i'm
maybe i live in a bubble the anger
element
that is being directed at the federal
reserve
well i think the the anger element
unfortunately right now is at sort of
like the
called the institutional level
where we understand their influence i
wonder if the
well i should take a step back yes for
the
for the retiree for that baby boomer
you're 100 right because they don't have
to know much about the fed
other than they're the reason why i get
0.1
in my cd so yes you're spot on
with 10 000 people every single day
turning 65
and the federal reserve has basically
screwed up
a lifelong retirement plan
because of what they've done to the
level of interest rates
and how they've forced people to take
extraordinary risk just to get some
return
i sort of feel that angst every day
because
a lot of our clients are just retirees
and hardworking people that
that are just like you know i i need i
need some income to live
right and and i try to spend every day
trying to find them
opportunities and and it seems like
every day that job gets harder and
harder
so yeah that anger is is being directed
at the fed
it should be directed at the fed and
and and you wonder like what reverses it
because if
we get a rise in rates then there is
going to be pain on the other side
but we need to we need to get out of the
of the model of japan we we need to
break free
but you there'll be pain that is
associated with that but
you know what if oil brainer replaces
jay powell you know all our wishes and
hopes will go out the window and we'll
just get more of the same modern
monetary theory
monetized even though i i will say this
is not a political political statement
but
i think congress can have sway
depending on what the outcome of the
election is just in terms of
reigning in the spending that is
authorized
and and you know we can stop and look
back as a nation and say wait a minute
maybe
maybe all this spending that's fueling
monetary policy is part of the cycle
that
we can't break is that they keep feeding
off of one another
well to that exact point i i do believe
that the administration
has become more sensitive to the
inflation talk
and even if inflation calms down they
they are at least being asked the
question is what do you think about
inflation now obviously you know even
jet you know led by janet yellen saying
it's all transitory but
that they're being asked the question i
think has maybe
tempered some of their ambitious uh
spending wants and that because they
know
i mean just look at the irony this week
that that that biden and company
are talking to opec in the saudis about
keeping the price of oil from going
higher
so they want to limit the amount of
drilling
but they want to have more drawing
to keep the level of oil prices from
going up so i think they've become
sensitive to this inflation discussion
because you
you have to believe that there are a lot
of constituencies out there calling
their congress people
every single day complaining about the
rising cost of this or that oh yeah
yeah relative in their lead yeah i mean
i can tell you that
that the the price of beef has nearly
doubled
in the space of 12 months in my house
and that's like something that you
really stop and pay attention to i mean
it's just
it's extraordinary and you say to
yourself you know how is this affecting
the average u.s household and and i
think that
maybe this is a good wake-up moment of
maybe turning the fiscal
spigots off and doing a little bit more
as you started out by saying
self-reflection um
well we're not going to figure out all
the problems of the world
today and we get to go fishing pretty
soon i'm really excited about that
but i i want to end today by bringing up
a really
momentous anniversary and having you
explain
uh the role that you played uh years ago
just a few years ago
uh when it comes to back to the future
which has just celebrated its
35-year anniversary and i'm joking with
you in a public forum on twitter about
it saying
nobody knows what i'm talking about
because it's an inside joke uh can you
tell us a little bit about
uh your son and a role that you played
so um my son's bar mitzvah back in
2015 while back now
uh we made it when i say we my wife and
my son and myself made a video
uh i rented a delorean and
we went uh he went with me being
playing doc brown took him back in time
to introduce himself to his parents that
had yet to have him
uh and to one day 13 years later
encourage him to study his torah portion
and
and learn his hebrew so he would be
ready for his
his bar mitzvah so i put on the uh the
doc brown costume
and didn't unfortunately i was not able
to drive the delorean but i
sat in a delorean with my son and we had
a little back to the future video
so well i if you and and also hired a
michael j fox look alike
to do a pass oh god so six years has
gone by but just the same
it was marvelous to watch uh peter and
uh on behalf of the producers i hope you
might be able to send us a screenshot
that we can put up
as well at the end of this interview i
look forward to
catching up a month from now let's let's
come back and
and revisit transitory uh in about oh i
don't
what did the atlanta fed president say
it was maybe nine to twelve months so
transitory is it being warped right as a
word
everyone's got their own definition but
let's come back
and and revisit this in nine to 12
months
and love that and uh and see where we
are with this great debate and in the
meantime i would so appreciate you
taking the time peter i'm grateful that
you had me
so much thank you well i hope you
enjoyed listening to peter bookfar
my brother from another mother uh as
much as i did
and it'll be interesting to see how this
inflation debate plays out
how is inflation affecting your life let
me know shoot me a comment
i'd be interested to hear it's certainly
something that we're all contending with
in different ways rising prices i would
suggest if you wanted to see the other
side
of that debate if you did miss a recent
interview that i did with david
rosenberg
go back and check that out have a look
just so you can see the two different
sides of the spectrum intellectually and
uh with that
i remind you please if you have not
subscribed
and i will see you next time for the
next down the middle thank you